don't care about sports it's like
billion dollar industry I don't even see
it really I just don't care what about
when like the Olympics come around well
the Olympics are different because
that's for gay people okay specifically
the Winter Olympics are for gay people
the wind tours
Anna Wintour Elizabeth it's Nick
actually I could call you Nick is
obsessed he doesn't know anything about
sports when it comes to the Olympics
he's like are you out of your mind this
woman cracked her knee trying to like he
just knows everything have you ever seen
selling Sunset yeah this is I've never
seen the latest season Nick called me he
goes I'm like what are you doing I just
finished selling Sunset season six okay
what happened well I'm gonna be honest
some people are born leaders Mary was
born a potato she's absolutely
Davina at this point is a plant that
shouldn't even be in the show they got
rid of Christine I mean it really Chris
Shell has now some sort of the bisexual
lesbian who the hell knows what's going
on with her none of them are selling
houses